was wir erreicht haben das ist ein
zwischenerfolg
nicht mehr und nicht weniger und ich
betone es ist ein zerbrechlicher
zwischen erfolgt mit diesen sätzen hat
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel den
deutschen klar gemacht dass die korona
krise noch in vollem gange ist und es
eben noch nicht viel spielraum gibt für
die heiß ersehnten lockerung immerhin
nächste woche dürfen die kleinen läden
wieder öffnen und ab dem vierten mai
soll die schule auch wieder schritt für
schritt starten
mit diesen kleinen ersten lockerungen
wollen bund und länder die menschen dazu
bewegen und motivieren durchzuhalten und
sich weiter an die regeln zu halten
erste lockerungen gibt es seit dieser
woche auch in österreich wie es dort und
in anderen ländern aussieht haben wir
unsere korrespondenten in europa und
rund um den globus gefragt
[Musik]
zunächst mal muss man sagen dass die
lockerungen nicht willkürlich ist
sondern die ausgangs beschränkungen
haben ganz klar messbare erfolge gezeigt
als man hier in österreich damit
angefangen hat gab es jeden tag 40
prozent mehr
corona infektionen getestet wurden ja
das ist ja alleine die testung und heute
ist man bei unter einem prozent
das ist also ein erheblicher unterschied
der durch diese ausgangs einschränkungen
erreicht wurde und die waren ja wirklich
sehr weitgehend ja also mit seit mitte
märz sind die schulen geschlossen alle
geschäfte hatten zu bis auf die
lebensmittelgeschäfte
es gab eine grundsätzliche anweisung
dass man nicht sich in der
öffentlichkeit bewegen darf außer zu
ganz bestimmten zweck nämlich um zur
arbeit zu gehen um anderen zu helfen um
lebensnotwendiges einzukaufen insofern
ist es auch gerechtfertigt dass jetzt
eine lockerung kommt und sicher gefällt
sich die österreichische regierung auch
darin so dazustehen als seien sie die
ersten und die vorreiter und das role
model für europa das ist eine rolle in
der sich sebastian kurz sehr gut gefällt
gerade auch in bezug auf die deutschen
da schielt man gerne drauf die in
frankreich ist jetzt gerade vom
präsidenten in einer fernsehansprache
angekündigt worden dass alle franzosen
noch vier wochen also bis zum 11
strikten ausgangssperren unterworfen
sind dass es tatsächlich eine sehr
strenge regelung hier man darf nur mit
passierschein vor die tür
ja für die franzose ist es eine etwas
missliche lage weil man das gefühl hat
man muss jetzt noch einen ganzen monat
abwarten aber ab dem 11 mai sollen dann
auch gleich die schulen wieder geöffnet
werden bislang hat der präsident nur
versprochen dass die regierung konkrete
pläne aus arbeitet also im gegensatz zu
deutschland das relativ niedrige
todeszahlen hat ist frankreich natürlich
sehr schockiert über 15.000 tote schon
und inzwischen kennen wirklich viele
über den bekannten oder familienkreis
leute die betroffen sind
deswegen ist hier doch eine erstaunliche
disziplin die leute haben eher das
gefühl es ist gut dass nicht zu schnell
gelockert wird
erstmal sind die beschränkungen im
moment sehr strikt und gerade auch in
new york aber eigentlich in den meisten
teilen des landes mittlerweile natürlich
sind alle restaurants bars sowie wie
überall arbeit das ist nach und nach
immer weiter verschärft worden
donald trump hat ja nun in der krise das
kann man bestimmt zu sagen grundsätzlich
eher langsam reagiert und was er auch
getan hat war dass er den einzelnen
bundesstaaten erst die verantwortung und
auch die schuld zugeschoben hat nun ist
es aber so wenn es um die lockerungen
geht nun will auf einmal trump die
autorität haben und sagt das ist meine
entscheidung nicht eure und wer hat auf
einer pressekonferenz in dieser woche ja
gesagt meine autorität ist total
das klingt natürlich etwas beängstigend
dass
wollen die gouverneure und vor allem
insbesondere unser new yorker gouverneur
eine promo allerdings nun nicht
mitmachen
como hat zb gerade eine allianz mit
allen möglichen anderen bundesstaaten
geschlossen um die lockerung zu
koordinieren und und er wehrt sich auch
ganz entschieden dagegen dass die
entscheidung bei trump legt er gerade im
fernsehen gesagt wir haben keinen könig
man sagt mir nicht vergessen dass jeder
schon zwei monate voraus ist das halt
die menschen sind hier schon sehr viel
länger all diesen einschränkungen
ausgesetzt viele menschen haben zwei
monate ihre wohnung gar nicht verlassen
jetzt in dieser situation sind in einer
phase wo man eben sehen muss ob es
möglich ist das leben wieder anfangen zu
lassen ohne dass die infektionszahlen
wieder hochgehen und sobald die zahlen
wieder hoch gehen werden die zügel
wieder angezogen und werden neue regeln
auch zum zahlen in sein zeil ich in
verschiedenen wohngebieten sind gelten
verschiedene regeln die einfach
gestrickten denn je nachgehen ob es gott
fälliger oder nicht zum beispiel hat die
chinesische regierung ist es jeder
massenveranstaltungen irgendwann werden
hier ein zwei jahre vergehen
die sehenswürdigkeiten sind in
größtenteils noch nicht wieder geöffnet
also die die regierung schafft hat
kleine inseln an normalität damit man
zumindest wieder arbeiten kann die
wirtschaft wird wieder angefahren aber
andere dinge sind hier eben erst mal
nicht möglich
also italien hat jetzt am
osterwochenende die marke von mehr als
20.000 toten in der provinz 19 krankheit
überschritten das hat das land natürlich
noch mal zusätzlich schockiert die phase
der großen nationalen einheit wir
schaffen das gemeinsam wir singen die
nationalhymne von den balkonen wir
hängen die nationalparke von
fenstersimsen und balkonbrüstungen diese
phase ist vorüber es wird jetzt versucht
die sogenannte phase 2 zu beginnen und
es gibt einen wirklich unübersichtlichen
flickenteppich
in italien jede region macht eigentlich
für sich alleine was sie für richtig
hält
die regierung in rom ist zögerlich vor
allem der sogenannte wissenschaftlich
technische beirat sagt wir dürfen nicht
zu schnell in diese phase 2 der
wiedereröffnung der wirtschaft eintreten
sonst droht uns die zweite welle der
krankheiten der infektionen
es gibt eine entspannung an der
gesundheits front aber es gibt starke
zunehmende spannungen an der front wenn
es darum geht die wirtschaft wieder in
gang zu bringen
jaja in singapur ist eigentlich in den
vergangenen wochen relativ gut gelaufen
kann man sagen die stadt ist natürlich
auch klein sie hatten 5,7 millionen
einwohner man kann sie also relativ gut
steuern und sie hat erfahrung mit
solchen dingen wie zum beispiel während
saß sammeln können im augenblick haben
wir aber gleichwohl die maßnahmen hier
verschärfen müssen dass jeder nur noch
mit max geboren das haus darf und nun
und dann wenn es extrem notwendig ist
und diese verschärfungen gehen jetzt bis
anfang mai bis zum 4
was jetzt schief gelaufen ist und so
großem entsetzen geführt hat ist der
umgang mit den gastarbeiter
sie leben in großen massen unterkünften
hintergrund seien auf 18 8 at zimmer und
die folge davon ist dass darko hohner
nun kassiert durch erste ansteckung und
jetzt sucht man händeringend und mit
großer kraft und mit dem militär was
eingesetzt wird etc
nach einer lösung für die gastarbeiter
problematisch
also hier in großbritannien heißt es
seit mehr als drei wochen stay at home
am donnerstag wird erwartet dass die
regierung stellung nimmt zu der frage
kann der lockdown beendet werden in
welcher form und in welchem zeitplan
zurzeit wird erwartet dass gesagt wird
wir machen weiter wie bisher und die die
maßnahmen vermutlich bis weit in den mai
hinein aufrecht erhalten werden
unklar ist in welcher form boris johnson
einbezogene sind diese entscheidung was
die erkrankung von johnson verändert hat
ist wahrscheinlich ein etwas milderer
blick auf die regierung also niemand war
in der zeit als er wirklich mit dem
leben rang in der stimmung die regierung
herrscht zu kritisieren das ändert sich
jetzt langsam wieder wo offenkundig ist
dass er auf dem weg der besserung ist
insgesamt wird sehr oft gefragt warum
laufen die dinge so viel schlechter in
großbritannien als etwa in deutschland
die leistungsfähigkeit des nhl es des
nationalen gesundheitsdienst wird von
manchen in zweifel gezogen von anderen
die fähigkeit die regierung den managers
ordentlich einzustellen aber insgesamt
gibt es ein gefühl dass dieses
großartige land von dem was johnson vor
der krisen immer gesprochen hat im falle
corona sich als mittelmäßig darstellt
die spanier und die meisten spanier
wirken sehr diszipliniert von anfang an
also es hat hier nicht lange gedauert
bis sich die leute umgestellt haben
auf diese ausgangs beschränkung das
heißt ja keine vollständige
ausgangssperre
man kann rausgehen ich war gerade auch
einkaufen supermarkt apotheke man kann
zeitungskiosk gehen davon zum arzt aber
das war's dann schon den applaus die man
jeden haben gemacht gehört der ist der
dank an die erste die krankenschwester
die pfleger die sanitäter ebenso viele
spanier
das war ein appell der der hier fast
endlich früchte getragen hat gehört
wurde
fast mehr als was die politiker gesagt
haben ich hier gibt es unterschiede zu
deutschland österreich und so es gibt
keine exit debatte in spanien also hier
rechnet keiner damit dass das jetzt
irgendwie ganz zu die gilt letzten
donnerstag wurde dieser sogenannte alarm
zustand erst mal um zwei weitere wochen
verlängert und im parlament hat es
damals schon gesagt sondern donnerstag
gesagt ich werde in zwei wochen wieder
hier stehen und ich werde das parlament
wieder darum bitten das zu verlängern
[Musik]